okay we go yeah why does international
mall securely on here condom or affirm
it early and he's got 2,300 which is
terrible for him he's usually around the
2500 mark so tariff hey great to to get
him at almost yeah really cooperating
okay rating doesn't matter much she of
course but it's still funny to observe
how the rating fluctuate sometimes for
four players okay played on only castles
in age three and there's a funny idea
with chief I if I want to try this out
it's maybe um yeah not entirely correct
but ok it's fun okay h5 come on just
going forward if it's down on 2300 maybe
is so in bad shape okay if I capture now
here and play Queen d7 SG Ford just
going down cannot play a three strange
as it looks here geforce just seems to
be just seems to be hanging
yeah this is really weird chess okay
yeah the g5 idea after white castles
only in place h3 so is this service well
it's not complete complete nonsense or
something okay I actually got this pawn
still not or not the end of the world of
course for white okay should it take now
what should I play capture myself always
unsure okay let's capture and retreat
the bishop it's just an it's an extra
porn after all but not not an automatic
window or something he still has got
some activity going for him with f5 and
d5 and so on he serves the squares but
there's no easy way with herbal for him
to get the porn back at least maybe i
should i should play 97 next 97 maybe 96
f for ya he cannot approach further with
the King's Own this also covers both
square cf5 and t5 nicely
maybe you should play d4 now trying to
get a bit of play in the center
and I stood season
doesn't know what what other ideas for
me here you had this not g 6 business 96
f form I hope it's not very unusual that
it doesn't move I just I still seem to
be connected here so strange of course
it's um yeah you went 45 tall okay I was
thinking about f 6 cm but then maybe you
can play d5 an IG form this would be a
this is an idea okay what if I'm capture
and play of six and we can so light
squares a lot now g6 immediately can
play d 5 it's not so easy what if i take
on b3 and play king e 6 king is six ok
can talk all day at least it keeps the
extra pony I can play f6 if necessary or
maybe even f5 trying to get rid of this
potential weaknesses the extra point is
not easy to convert anyway
yeah not easy not easy at all maybe I
did term I'm I played something
inaccurate before we replaced for
instance some move like kings you form
play f6 and d5 and it's it's not moving
something's something's off with them
maybe it's got some internet issues or
something is playing really slow usually
it's a pretty quick player I'm the one
usually am being a time travel okay
maybe 95 to to come
yeah yes I mentioned it's not not at all
easy to to convert the poor Nia trying
to cover c7 in case of 95 don't have I
don't really have no idea at the moment
how to make progress yeah this is this
is just just difficult to maybe row
gauge form gauge for he takes takes King
takes and then look g8 rook GA g5 trying
to to get to this pawn yeah maybe just
an idea to get rid of the activity that
he has I'm also threatening with g2 and
district doesn't have any squares for
innovation I'm covering all this nicely
yeah I expected this but I thought route
to know what you two okay some lot down
on time f 6 57 year of course but I can
take hear it here Roxy seven rupee three
gives me two extra points at this one
hmm okay
okay okay so check white forfeits on
time yeah okay I need to win on time
once and awhile as well it was somewhat
strange that he played so slowly once
suddenly is usually not such a slow
player maybe he's had too much red wine
or something okay yeah let's go on with
a new one